crypto ft blog chain man hört momentan
nichts anhatte mal genau diese sollten
wir vor zwei wochen schon mal sind alle
das club momentan komplett enthalten ist
es werden millionen investiert millionen
gewonnen und auch millionen verloren und
obwohl der preis unfassbar schnell
steigt ist es nicht möglich mit unserem
2800 euro innerhalb von sieben tagen
reich zu werden oder eine rolex
finanzieren zu können
außer es gäbe eine möglichkeit mit mehr
geld zu handeln als wir zur verfügung
haben
warte mal diese option gibt viel spaß
mit durch crypto leverage trading zu
holen was geht ab willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren vollen rolex heute geht
es wieder einmal um drücke aber dieses
mal richtig dass er gerne like da
verkehrt sich den kern als abonnieren
weil dann werdet ihr sehr schnell sehr
reich genauso wie in den letzten folgen
heute werden wir probieren durch crypto
handel reich zu werden oder näher zu
rolex zu kommen und das ganze
funktioniert natürlich nicht wenn wir
ganz normal drückt zu kaufen und warten
sondern wir müssen wieder hebeln könnte
uns bekannt vorkommen wir haben bereits
schon mal aktien gekauft die auch wir
haben das schon mal mit aktien gemacht
damals haben wir irgendwelche kreuzfahrt
aktien gekauft und diesen super cars
durch die decke gegangen mit einem
zehner hebel heute machen wir das ganze
wieder oder in den nächsten sieben tagen
nach mir das ganze wieder nur mit
cryptic der markt ist aber volatil der
bewegt sich also sehr krass das bedeutet
wir können entweder sehr schnell sehr
reich werden oder sehr schnell unser
gesamtes geld verlieren zieht man dazu
in betracht dass ich absolut gar keine
ahnung habe was ihnen in den nächsten
tagen treten wird und was sonst auch
passiert könnte das ganze nicht
besonders gut ausgeben
h
andererseits bin ich dave und ich glaube
ich habe immer das fünkchen glück das
uns dabei hilft vielleicht zu werden
natürlich gibt's auch updates zu den
paar sachen aus der letzten woche die
beiden grünen habe ich an kollegen
weiter gegeben deswegen obviously kein
wort gemacht die große shopping welt
haben wir mit etwas über 100 europas
verkauft und diese kleine etui mit
irgendwie 20 euro pro kind oder so um
erst danach übrigens aufgefallen dass
tatsächlich sachen gibt die extra für
den autos produziert werden
deswegen hatte ich schwierigkeiten
manche sachen einfach so auf der
fahrerseite und so zu finden
und jetzt geht es weiterhin mit video
der aktuelle stand im rolex trade up ist
folgender und von diesem geld werden wir
mit 1500 euro probieren leverage crypto
trailing stop flüge wir machen das nicht
mit 1500 sondern nur mit 1000 euro
ich habe mich hingesetzt und ein account
eröffnet natürlich hat es wieder zwei
tage verifizierung gedauert und im
endeffekt hat mir das direkt den arsch
gehörte der kräfte markt ist in den
letzten zwei tagen komplett abgestürzt
die preise sind so günstig wie seit vier
monaten oder so nicht mehr und dadurch
haben wir jetzt natürlich ein top
einstieg und hätte die verifizierung
nicht zwei tage gedauert hätten wir
jetzt wahrscheinlich so 50 prozent von
unserem geld verloren
oder vielleicht sogar alles mein account
ist auf jeden fall redding wir haben
aber direkt durch den partys ein
bisschen geld verloren also wenn man
insgesamt 30 euro fließt bezahlt um das
geld von der kreditkarte auf den
leverage kaum zu bekommen schwierig aber
diesen prophet müssen wir in irgendeiner
weise wieder rausholen es gibt so grob
zwei optionen die wir jetzt in dieser
woche probieren könnte wirklich zu
daytrading also ganz kurze minimale
kursbewegungen mitzunehmen schnell zu
kaufen schnell zu verkaufen oder einen
kleineren hebel zu benutzen und einfach
lange position zu halten vielleicht über
die gesamten sieben tage das problem an
der sache
ich habe mich seit zwei jahren nicht
mehr mit kultur beschäftigt das letzte
mal war ende 2018 da hat das alles super
gut funktioniert ich hatte eine menge
glück und habe seitdem die finger davon
gelassen jetzt muss ich mich als aller
erstes mal wieder ein bisschen reinlesen
welche assets welche projekte sind die
mit hoher volatilität also viel bewegung
wo wir dann viel gewinnen oder auch viel
verlust machen können das alles muss
jetzt herausfinden ich schaue mir noch
mal alles genauer an wie es mit dem
hebeln funktioniert so dass ich mich
nicht geisteskrank verschuldet und dann
können wir eigentlich starten
allererstes habe ich mich wieder durch
so halb seriöse youtube videos in das
thema eingearbeitet und herausgefunden
dass es vermutlich am schlafen wäre die
großen assets wie die theorien bitcoin
oder gar download zu kaufen und es
vielleicht keinen sinn machen würde
absolutes it all points kaufen deswegen
bleibe ich bei den basics das sollte
eigentlich überhaupt nicht passieren
aber ich habe gerade obwohl ich
eigentlich nur testen wollte für 300
dollar betreuen mit einem fünfer hebel
gekauft bitcoin mit einem fünfer hebel
gekauft was zur hölle bedeutet dass im
endeffekt gibt einem die bank der broker
eine möglichkeit sich geld zu leihen und
mit mehr geld zu handeln als man
eigentlich zur verfügung hierbei gibt es
zwei große unterschiede einmal groß das
bedeutet es gibt eine möglichkeit sich
absolut verschulden oder eine isolierte
variante bei der ab einem bestimmten
preis wenn der kurs in die falsche
richtung geht man einfach seine gesamte
position verliert das bedeutet nicht nur
dass man mehr gewinne machen kann weil
man sich geld geliehen hat sondern man
kann auch tatsächlich mehr verlust
machen mein plan ist es nämlich für
diese woche bitcoin und kriterium die
beiden größten und bekanntesten konto
markt mit dem film hebel zu kaufen und
eine woche laufen zu lassen wir haben
gerade einen super günstigen einstieg
die preise sind niedrig und wir gehen
mit dem verhältnismäßig niedrigen hebel
rein und hoffen auch dass der kurs in
den nächsten tagen deutlich steigen wird
und wir eben mit 5 fachen gewinn
beteiligt werden
wenn ich beide kunst mit 300 euro kaufen
würde das bedeuten dass 350
beziehungsweise 370 euro übrig bleiben
um wirklich mit hohen hebeln bisschen
day zu traden kümmere mich jetzt
allerdings als erste noch darum eine
zweite say für position aufzumachen
namen und einen jungen
weil wir gerade hier auf einem
abwärtstrend sind
ach weißte was im endeffekt macht auch
überhaupt keinen unterschied wir kaufen
einfach also wenn wir unsere bitcoin und
die terium positionen auf gemacht die
ich jetzt für 7 tage laufen lassen und
das was ich hier sind ist der
liquidation preis bei dem unsere
position komplett aufgelöst wird für die
gesamte position verlieren und das
gesamte geld an die bank geht in dem
moment in dem man sich geld bei der bank
light also hebelt wird eine grenze
festgesetzt der sogenannte liquidation
preis bei dem man sein gesamtes geld
verliert wenn der kurs in die falsche
richtung geht würde eine terium in
unseren gedanken konzept beim kauf
tausend euro kosten und danach auf 900
euro fallen könnte es also passieren
dass es zum sogenannten margin call
kommt was übersetzt einfach heißt dass
man sein gesamtes investment verliert 2
das letzte mal dass itellium beim
liquidation preis von uns war war
gestern
es ist also wirklich hey hey usa eben
bei report wir werden sehen ob wir in
dieser woche in irgendeiner weise etwas
tun können jetzt probiert irgend welche
strategien zu finden wie ich vielleicht
als sei in irgendeiner weise eine chance
haben damit hoch gehebelten all points
ein bisschen profit zu machen keine
ahnung wie das gehen soll
in meinem ersten super ski date rape
habe ich mit 25 der hebel kadaver
gekämpft ganz ganz krank wissen zehn
minuten drin und unser investment mit 25
der hebel ist 36 prozent im plus
aber wir haben nichts gewonnen so lange
wir nicht realisieren muss so sagen es
ist wirklich extrem aufregend auch wenn
das vielleicht einfach er dieses
glücksspiel gefühlt ist weil das was ich
gerade mache mit der ahnung die ich habe
eher glücksspiel ist als dass es in
irgendeiner weise berechnet oder
vernünftig durch gedacht ist es
unfassbar genauso schnell wie ich jetzt
hier gerade meine zahlen steigen sehen
könnte
die genau andere richtung gehen und wir
könnten alles verlieren aber so wie es
gerade aussieht wenn ich jetzt älter
verkaufen würde wären wir bei circa 30
prozent
das ist halt komplett komplett geistig
gestört das ist wirklich das ist mit
nichts zu vergleichen
let's go
das war unser erster richtiger date rape
und wir haben 0,001 3x petri lust
gemacht was zum jetzigen kurs 40 euro
entspricht
das war jetzt aber ein profit von 40 es
fühlt sich zu leicht haben und genau das
ist das was gefährlich ist kein witz tag
nur zwei es könnte nicht besser laufen
40 euro plus durch unseren date rape
gestern und unsere langen positionen mit
0,5 ebel stehen gerade bei 0,00 0 4
bitcoin im plus 0,002 und 0,00 preisen
das bedeutet wir sind bei 0,0 0 6 2
bitcoin im plus 40 euro wir sind nach
einem tag 240 euro man muss aber dazu
sagen wir haben natürlich nichts
gewonnen so lange wir die positionen
nicht realisiert haben großer vorteil
daran dass die position gut stehen ist
einfach dass wir uns weiter von unserem
liquidation preis entfernen wo wir die
komplette position verlieren würden es
steht also sehr gut um das dieswöchige
projekt vielleicht dass man das sogar
noch länger als eine woche lang war
dreist ist der absolute trauen unsere
ganzen long-term investments laufen
super gut ich hab mich dagegen
entschieden jetzt weiter zu daytrading
weil alle crypto währungen alle
positionen die man weniger als ein jahr
lang hält müssen versteuert werden und
deswegen macht es für mich relativ wenig
sinn den ganzen tag irgendwelche micro
beträge hin und her zu traden zum einen
blick ich bei dem steuer kam nicht so
richtig durch und zum anderen weiß ich
aber dass ich die sachen besteuern
müsste und dadurch der gewinn natürlich
gesperrt wird und ich habe gerade mal
zusammengerechnet wir stehen gerade bei
1.515 euro am dritten tag es ist
unglaublich super super super gefährlich
aber sieht wunderbar aus die frage nicht
und für das projekt nicht einfach
vielleicht jetzt an diesem punkt hier
beenden soll
was wollen wir mehr ich habe keine
ahnung ob es nicht wieder dropped und
lieber 500 euro mitnehmen als nicht
morgen darüber abfangen das ist gar
nichts habe
ich stelle jetzt einfach mal ein take
profit ein also ich sage wenn die
währung so und so viel wert ist dann
verkauft meine gesamte position jetzt
gerade haben wir noch kein geld verdient
weißt du man denkt war cool die die
kurse sind mega hoch aber solange du die
position nicht verkauft hast hast du zum
einen nichts verloren und zum anderen
aber auch nichts geworden das gilt es
einfach nur zu hoffen das ist noch mal
ein bisschen steigt das wäre jetzt
wirklich der absolute traum und ich
schätze dass wir dann so bei 650 euro im
plus sein soll
es sind 24 stunden vergangen seitdem wir
unsere verkaufs positionen eingesetzt
haben und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt ob
irgendwas verkaufen konnten könnten wir
nicht die preise im geist kranke fallen
unser profil des übels
zusammengeschrumpft wir sind mit bitcoin
26 prozent im minus
wir sind nur drei prozent mit einer im
plus und wir sind nur 18 prozent mit
insgesamt gerechnet auch im salz seit
beginn es gestern noch gesagt das lieber
raus gehen ja das hier ist der terium
schaaf in köln chart download charts
ein weiterer standhafter tag im
leveraged trading projekt wir schauen
sofort rein ich ahne schlimmes
beziehungsweise nichts mega gutes das
ganze wäre auch kein problem wenn wir
nicht gebühren für den hebel bezahlen
würden krank wir sind 50 prozent im
minus 30 prozent im minus um zehn
prozent im minus
was das aber bedeutet wir kaufen jetzt
nach
oh mann alter erinnert ihr euch vor zwei
tagen habe ich auch gesagt ja heute
müssen wir eigentlich raus und das
mitnehmen ich habe die geldpreise und
stückchen höher angesetzt die wurde
nicht ausgelöst und ab da ging's
komplett berg absoluter reinfall
wirklich alle alles rot weiß wir müssen
uns definitiv länger laufen lassen sei
aber nur eine chance wenn wir jetzt die
theorie um nachkaufen geht unser
locations preis auch noch weiter runter
weil wir gerade im minus sind 13
contractor terium usb-port s2000 trian
group nennt ihn in trance wir haben
nachgekauft ich glaube dass die einzige
option die wir jetzt gerade haben und
hoffe mal dass wir unsere position nicht
komplett verlieren und das in den
nächsten wochen weitergeht der
allerletzte tag das große finale wie
viel geld haben wir gewonnen wie viel
geld haben wir verloren wo stehen wir
gerade können wir die krypto währungen
rausholen lassen wir die krypto währung
noch über ein paar wochen drin
wie sieht es aus der große moment wir
locken uns ein echter wieder 51 prozent
im plus
terium 15 prozent im plus und bitcoin
-25 gut könnte besser sein aber sitzt
sieht nicht so schrecklich aus wie
gestern also eigentlich alles bestens
ich habe mich tatsächlich schon darauf
eingestellt gehabt dass wir das jetzt
über den nächsten wochen noch drin
lassen ist vielleicht auch ganz
interessant weil dann können wir in der
nächsten woche noch mal darauf eingehen
und gucken wie es aussieht und dann
vielleicht das große geld machen wir
wissen es nicht vergesst nicht den kanal
zu abonnieren damit ihr die update davon
nicht verpasst und natürlich auch die
ganzen anderen verrückten aktion die wir
machen um zurückzukommen vergesst nicht
das video zu leiten wenn es euch
gefallen hat wir sehen uns nächste woche
wieder macht es gut
[Musik]